[Music]
in no more gawking news
what's cocking like that's right yeah Oh
mouth-breathing I'm staring submitted by
Savannah from Chile hello Amsterdam
we'll be cracking down on tourists in
the red-light district
oh come on that's not fair Amsterdam air
yeah have you guys ever been caught
gawking at somebody no I have really
but this dumb [ __ ] didn't
understand what I was going at because I
was in k-town at a Denny's at like 2:00
a.m. I was mad hungry and I was looking
at this this girl had you know the
chicken tender the the sampler platter
oh yeah so it was him and his girl and I
was staring at the chicken tender like
this the sampler plate he's like what's
up what you looking at dude I was like
the chicken tenders those the mozzarella
sticks home dude it looks so [ __ ]
good and when she bit into it the steam
came up oh I'm so hungry
I think I'm like they'll catch me but
then once they catch me I'll end up
saying it loudly like for example if I'm
staring at someone's baby or something
and then they catch me staring at the
baby I'll tell whoever I'm with like
look how cute the baby is like so they
know why oh that's right son like you
analyze everything have you ever just
had like a brain fart and you're not
gawking but you're just staring and they
get into your life yeah and then they're
like why looking at me and I'm like I
was looking they've called you out like
that that's rude no I think they say it
in their eyes I've never heard how much
conversation happens that never happens
but Joe thinks that happen here like
tentative okay I understand what they're
saying red they're my eyes recently at
an audition I was talking at a bunch of
women just because I walked into this
audition and for some reason it was just
like 30 of the most beautiful women I've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life and I was
just like what is this role and I think
and I think it was for a role for a
prostitute so but it was amazing that I
was sitting there just like what is
going on like what what is what
happening I feel like I got got people
because I like to build back stories
around them like oh yeah you just start
thinking like okay like we're there
where'd they come from where they're
going like why are they doing that
what's happening what are they talking
about like to do I'm doing that and and
I've never gotten caught really though
so every time like someone looks over
I'm like very aware of them looking guys
used to do this when you were younger
when you see a dude and you're like I
wonder if I could like [ __ ] or he could
[ __ ] me up I still do that today
Oh shadow anymore but some people I look
at and I'm like I wonder what they look
like having sex yeah yeah there's just
some people that you look at make it be
for good reason ever happy all together
or that even though yeah I think I'd do
the same thing where I create backstory
something yeah yeah if it's a couple
I'll do that like I'll be like how does
that I can't I don't think I could
picture that I'm like Shaq and his wife
oh yeah I always pictured having sex
wait what wait wait what you always
picture him having sex yeah I just
assume like all the walls in his house
have like a big-ass Hall through the
drywall but it's like every time he
humps it's just like dish once he
thrusted into his wife her [ __ ]
kneecaps are back here maybe the only
way she can orgasm maybe she needs a bad
[ __ ] I will say this I knew somebody
that hooked up with chef actually she
did it her friend it you know like he's
back on the way but she said that he
doesn't have a very long penis but it
looks like a soda can it's an widest one
it's probably know it's probably not
long in comparison I'll talk here he's
seven feet it was like huge yeah but it
probably could be like 12 inches
she said that his penis was very wide
okay yeah big soda can that's a
briolette soup can yeah it's like some
[ __ ] like that but I was like oh
interesting now I know what sex this was
smart water bottle how do you even like
get that it that's like fisting I guess
well then we could give birth so that's
a pretty good size that can actually go
through that yeah but it takes nine
months of your body prepping for that
[ __ ] to happen
I'm saying I've seen some videos that
will make you change your mind about how
much that can stretch oh yeah oh yeah
I've seen one where a guy with his head
in there oh that's crazy no it was like
that wife so it was like a corner bed
you've seen that the real thing I don't
know I'm talking about though the
roundball corner bed yeah a corner bed
post and she's like writing a pose that
looks like the size of a [ __ ] chest
piece pawn that's like this huge and I'm
like what the [ __ ]
and if that is not pleasurable no
there's no guys could [ __ ] dip there
is I'm saying if you're really loose and
like that it's just so stretched out
that like the only way it feels good is
if you have something that massive so
[ __ ] not that won't feel good the
vagina but the whole part are the
insecticides with the inside is with
straight yeah cuz they're too many too
many big things went up there I didn't
even know that would get stretched now I
don't know a whole it get stretch not
not the inside part sometimes I look at
the the size of the dildo and I'm like
man that's insane like that's like an
elephant's trunk like like oh he's so
offended who I just don't know like is
it like a gauge where they started with
a little build oh and it got bigger the
butt hole was like that but I don't know
I don't know magic trick it's it's it's
Sherlock Holmes over here
no wonder they have these ping pong
[ __ ] shows in Thailand you know it's
like it's like a freak show ping pong
with each other yeah like they pop ping
pong is out of the person twice
yeah they shoot it out I've seen the
cigar smoking out of a vagina remember
how does your Amsterdam and they [ __ ]
pull birds out of a vagina [ __ ]
oh my god the bird is like that's
unsanitary birds have diseases yeah sort
of vaginas your vagina just so disease
the bird gets a disease and it's like ah
these is when they're born like that the
mom has a vaginal infection the bird
comes up alright so Amsterdam here the
tourists and Amsterdam are being told to
stop gawking at the sex workers then why
would they have them and big [ __ ]
display windows it doesn't extend cuz
it's like this I get what they're saying
it's like if you're not gonna buy
anything quit [ __ ] coming here what
if you're deciding whether yeah yeah you
can't have your [ __ ] out it's maybe not
to look
that's what window shopping is all about
you gotta see I do that with shoes I
look at them I'm like hmm Mike maybe I
do have a dress that could do that like
I'm gauging whether or not it's worth it
and you're still gonna buy right maybe
maybe maybe I'm like none of these shoes
don't coming tonight so they're
implementing restrict new rules that
will come into effect in April crazy
they're saying that shouting alcohol and
drug use are forbidden on tours and that
visitors will no longer be able to take
photos oh they were never allowed to
take photos yes I don't know okay well
you're not allowed to well no longer and
and they're also telling tour tour
operators that tours must stop at 11
p.m. and that they are limited to 20
people and that if some of these tour
operators if they don't follow these
strict rules it will be hit with fines
and yeah and they're just saying like
you know you have to respect the sex
workers you can't just and I get it
stare at them all day it's probably 80
to 90 percent tourists best just coming
in taking pictures gawking and doing all
that and they're like yo man if you're
not gonna buy no [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
yeah they can't leave their tour to go
yeah and I bet you more guys are gonna
be ashamed to actually walk in and do
all that stuff because there's
so many people like you would think that
right but that's not what oh really you
don't see that like they just get in
there yeah like no one it doesn't feel
uptight the way you would think it looks
like you're judged yeah yeah like I I
felt at Ikes I'm from the US but then
you see guys and they're like they're
like just they're like wow look at that
and they're like talking about it and
like I like horrid titties uh yeah like
you can tell that it's like a good thing
and they don't they have no shame and
like just like chillin outside having a
cigarette just like yeah yeah like it's
normal so like they're at a car
dealership Guinea what do you want I
want the Ferrari yeah I didn't feel very
judgy like you know it didn't feel it
tight what are you doing today cheap to
like they're gorgeous
yeah like okay so so we were with
Steve's brother and Steve's brother is
single and he went through the red light
district and he's like I saw the most
gorgeous woman I've ever seen in my
freakin life and I had to ask like how
much because I had to know like how much
is the most gorgeous woman worth 60
bucks 60 bucks for what for I think I
don't know an hour I guess but that was
like the that was like the starting room
yeah they need to come to America
because they're selling themselves short
they'll make hundreds and thousands over
here sad I was reading a story that a
lot of them are kind of trapped there Oh
were they oh they wanted to be dancers
and like um they heard like that they
could become a dancer if they did enough
time in the red-light district and it
never happens there just because it
makes the dicks it should just be a
union and stuff over there though and
make health insurance and all kinds of
stuff but they're stuck there I heard
that some of them actually have a
boyfriend but their boyfriend kind of
pimps them out to do that that's that
that's so their their boyfriend is like
you know like that the pretty boy that
will like just kind of romance them ed
in so they're emotionally attached to
the guy so then they'll don't do the
work they're legal prostitute they'll do
the work but they come home and give all
their money to their boyfriend I like it
when the girls are empowered I don't
like it yeah like put in that position
and they feel oppressed I like you one
of the girls like yeah I like the [ __ ]
and I want
money Oh like strippers that like really
like like they own it yeah they like it
makes me feel a power there's a really
good documentary about the different
types of sex work that exists like
there's a brothel that legal brothel in
Australia and a lot of the women there
were more so empowered because they
control everything they don't have a
pimp they don't have any of that stuff
versus you know like some of the
brothels that are illegal and stuff
there they're all sex slaves and whatnot
and then there's also like those super
high ask like s course that can make
like fifty thousand over a weekend and
all that yeah because they're like
part-time girlfriends to these
millionaires and stuff and I'm like this
is crazy but what it boiled down to is
most men want emotional like comfort or
whatever they don't know how to ask for
it hmm a lot of the prostitutes were
saying sometimes guys just want to talk
or they just want to hang out because
her friend has it yeah she's like a
pearl Hoel right yeah go and play video
games with the dude yeah you're dealing
with mega rich dudes that spent so much
time on their business or whatever that
they didn't really work on that social
life they don't know how to get a girl
and it's so weird right so they just pay
for affection and pay for to make this
up no [ __ ]
yeah it it's mainly emotional oh yeah
it's crazy
[Music]